in this video we're going to talk about
coordinate proofs and geometry and more
specifically we're going to talk about
how do you prove that a quadrilateral a
four-sided figure is a parallelogram so
let's dive into this video there's five
different ways that you can show that a
quadrilateral is a parallelogram you
could show that both pairs of opposite
sides are parallel that's the definition
you could show that the diagonals bisect
each other they cut each other in half
you could show that one pair of opposite
sides is parallel and congruent you
could show that both pairs of opposite
sides are congruent and then the last
one you can show that both pairs of
opposite angles are congruent we're
going to do four of these different
techniques and we're going to be using
the slope formula the midpoint formula
and the distance formula so you might
want to memorize these and write these
down if you haven't already so let's
just say we're given this quadrilateral
ABCD and we've got the coordinates here
listed and I've plotted in the X Y plane
so let's do this first method of showing
that it's a parallelogram by showing
that both pairs of opposite sides are
parallel now when we find the slope of a
line if two lines have the same slope
that means that they'll never cross that
means that they're parallel they're
going up at the same rate and if we show
that these two pairs of opposite sides
have the same slope they're parallel and
we'll have proved that this is a
parallelogram so let's go ahead and do
that so we're going to start off with
this slope formula Y2 minus y1 over X2
minus X1 and let's go ahead and do I'll
just write number one here so this is
going to be M the slope of let's say a d
so between A and D so we're going to do
Y2 minus y1 so this is going to be 2
minus negative 1 over
X2 minus X1 so that's 1 minus negative
1. now when you subtract it's like
adding the opposite
so you can see we're getting 3 over 2.
so that's right here so I'm just going
to make a little note here that the
slope is equal to three halves we might
need that later now let's go ahead and
do this other side here BC so let's say
the slope
of BC is equal to negative 2 minus
negative 5.
over 2 minus 0.
okay so when you subtract it's like
adding the opposite so that's going to
give us 3 over 2 and you can see that
they're the same slope so that means
that they're parallel
so I'm just going to indicate on the
diagram here with a little arrow
to show that those are parallel okay now
let's go ahead and find these two sides
a b and c d so what's the slope of a b
well let's see slope of a b is equal to
Y2 minus y1
and just keep in mind that the order is
important so if I did Y2 minus y1 this
way I have to do X2 minus X1 that same
order here I'm doing Y2 minus y1 so I'm
going to do X2 minus X1 the order is
important otherwise you're going to get
a little bit different answer so this
comes out to 4 over 1 which is 4.
okay so let's just write that down slope
equals 4.
and then over here for CD
we've got negative 1 minus negative 5
over negative 1 minus
zero
okay so that comes out to 4 over
negative 1. oh I see where I made a
mistake 1 minus 2 is negative 1. okay so
these both have a slope of negative four
so that is interesting because they both
have the same slope so that means that
these guys are going to be parallel to
one another
and we've proved that it was a
parallelogram so that was method number
one showing both pairs of opposite sides
are parallel okay so good so let's go on
to example number two let's prove that
this is a parallelogram by showing that
the diagonals they bisect each other
that means they cut each other in half
if they cut each other in half that
means that they're going through each
other's midpoint okay one another is
midpoint so we're going to use the
midpoint formula here and we're going to
use the midpoint of the opposite
vertices so what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to say the
midpoint of AC
and the midpoint what we're doing is
we're finding the average so we're
adding the X's together and dividing by
two and we're adding the Y's together
and dividing by two so we have one plus
zero
divided by two
and we have 2 plus negative five
divided by two and so that comes out to
one half and negative three over two
now let's do the midpoint for
DB or BD however you want to say that b
d and so we're going to do the midpoint
again so we're going to say negative 1
plus 2
divided by 2 and negative 1 plus
negative 2
divided by 2. and if we simplify that
let's see we get one over two
and negative 3 over 2
and you can see that these guys are the
same they match that means that they are
bisecting each other they're going
through each other's midpoints so that's
method number two here that we showed
that it's a parallelogram because the
diagonals so if you can draw this here
accurately
are bisecting each other so let's see is
this one half negative one and a half
yeah pretty close Okay my diagram's not
perfect but you got it so let's go to
the third example here let's show that
one pair of opposite sides is parallel
and congruent now we've already
established that let's say these two
sides here are parallel but are they the
same length so here we're going to be
using the distance formula to find the
length of a d and the length of BC so
let's go ahead and do that so we're
going to do the distance
of a d
and so here we're going to use the
square root let's make a little room
here square root
of the difference in the x coordinate
squared plus the difference in the y
coordinate Square to add those together
and take the square root so we've got 1
minus negative 1. which is 2 squared and
2 minus negative 1 which is 3 squared so
that comes out to 4 plus 9 that's the
square root of 13. so let's just write
that down square root of 13. and if we
do the length of CD we're going to do
the distance of CD same formula it's
going to be did I say CD CB CB
because we're doing the opposite side
showing those are congruents we have 2
minus 0 which is 2 squared plus negative
2 minus negative 5 which is negative 3
squared that comes out to 4 plus 9 which
is also the square root of 13. so see
how these match
so what that tells us is that the
opposite sides are parallel and
congruent and that's method number three
here
ordered the number doesn't matter but
just to show you that we're going
through the different types and then the
fourth one is to show that both pairs of
opposite sides are congruent well we've
already shown that a d and c b are
congruent we just need to show that a b
and c d are also congruent so we're
going to do the distance formula two
more times so we're going to do the
distance of a b
let's see which comes out to 1 minus 2
is negative 1 squared so that's negative
1 squared
Plus
let's see 2 minus negative 2 which is 4
squared so that comes out to let's see
do they make a mistake uh let's see 2
minus negative 2 is 4 squared
okay good yep so that comes out to the
square root of 17. okay good and then
we're going to do the distance of this
side here CD
which is equal to the square root of
negative 1 minus 0 which is negative 1
squared plus negative 1 minus negative
five which is four squared so that also
comes out to the square root of 17. so
we prove now that these two sides are
congruent so we've got both pairs of
opposite sides congruent that was method
number four and then method number five
this one's a little bit more challenging
diving into the angle measures we'll
leave that one for now but we can see
that there's these are the ways that you
would approach these coordinate proofs
using the midpoint formula the slope
formula the distance formula and you
might want to just be very organized the
way that you notate everything so notice
I'm using distance with the sub script
here A D so I know that's the distance
of a d Etc so I hope that helps you
understand coordinate proofs a little
bit better
great job I'll see you in the next video